drue good morning how are you I'm doing
great yeah don't forget about my time
with the bills now - man I love playing
in the Western in western New York okay
it was great out there you have jerseys
from the bills and the Cowboys probably
at your home I do yeah and you have your
Patriots Jersey yeah of course of course
did you ever exchange jerseys you know I
did I've got a few you know I'm not a
big memorabilia collector but but
there's some stuff that's just so damn
cool that that you have to do in so I've
got you know I've got one of one of
Elwes helmets but not like the you know
a prom helmet was actually his helmet
you know it's like the one you can do
you know they had the speakers in it for
the different is the real deal that's
good I was and it was the old one too is
the old you know kind of the more what
royal blue instead of the really dark
blue the the old original you know
Broncos helmet so I've got that one I've
got
oh she's like some Steve Young and
merino and Jim Kelly you know all these
guys that were my idols growing up that
I got to play against and so those are
those ones are really cool but I don't
have a ton of them but those ones are
cool did you keep anything from the
cameo in the movie Jerry Maguire
did you you know what I didn't because I
well I was if you go back and look at
that it's sort of it's pretty funny it
actually kind of goes right with the
music you were just playing it's pretty
dated but I was wearing my own clothes
and when I was when I was there and I
but I didn't steal anything off of the
set I died you know in hindsight I
probably should've if a quarterback had
a walk-up song what would yours be oh
that's a great question
you know I mean I you know I I mean I
would just I would have to go with
something that just you know just got me
fired up so you know I mean probably I
would probably go with some Metallica or
something like that back in the day I'd
you know and this this it gets even more
dated I do you know when I when I my
first start ever in college in 1990 with
the Washington State Cougars I remember
clearly I was I had my discman in the
locker room and I
listening whoo and I was listening to
you thunderstruck by ac/dc before I took
the field yeah
my not yeah absolutely get fired up
right yeah hey I noticed you were quoted
of what continues to motivate Tom Brady
because I think that's usually your
desire like you still want to play but
sometimes you just don't put in the
effort it feels like you know anybody in
any walk of life when you've been doing
something for such a long period of time
he seemed like he was the 20-year old
quarterback at the end of the game you
know instead of Patrick mahomes his
excitement when he was being interviewed
after they won that game you would have
thought he's never been to the Super
Bowl before so what motivates Brady you
know that's so that's the amazing thing
to me you know I mean it doesn't matter
what you do that when you've been when
you've been at the same job with the
same boss and the head and go to the
same office for you know going on 20
years now you know I can start to get a
little stale after a while but he just
he still does loves it he loves
preparing do it loves loves to to go out
there and compete and and and still is
doing an extremely high level obviously
so yeah I don't know it's sort of it's
it's it's a really cool thing to watch
yeah he and then Drew Brees and the same
in the same boat now he's you know Brees
you know made one move but you know but
he's been doing it for a long time and
both of those guys seem to just have
that young man's passion when they when
they take the field in his free makes
her pretty fun to watch him but you
jokes last year I think you were joking
that Tom Brady should go into the Hall
of Fame for just putting up with Bill
Belichick yeah well I mean think about
it you know I mean you know you look at
at at Belichick and he's obviously gonna
good honestly you know one of the
greatest coaches in any sport and
certainly a football but you know he's
not it's not it's not a real not a real
fun day we work for give me an example
now not a lot of laughing and joking oh
you know buddy the examples are so
mundane and boring that you know that
it's there's not even really learned
really good stories but you know I do
recall Tom at one point telling me that
you know I go to work with the dead and
they'd been together for a long time at
this point in a lot of days where
Belichick we're gonna walk by him alone
just ghost him does not even say hi you
know but it's just not a friend it's
just not a friendly place to be but but
obviously extremely effective for both
of them and and how is that possible
drew that Brady's in the hall and Bella
checks in the hall and Bella check
doesn't say anything I don't know him he
may have been joking I don't even know
but but it said but it's just a bits
just it's just all business and that's
what they do and it's been really really
effective for both of them oh my gosh
how would you know we keep looking at
this play in New Orleans so it was a
former quarterback and how could we do
this to make sure that we don't make
that mistake again in a big moment like
that what would be your suggestion man
that's that's like that's a great
question because it's not past
interference so you it's not one of
those from the standpoint of his cold
past interference so I can't review it
it it wasn't called to review yeah when
it's not called there's no there's
really no answer for it currently I
don't know I mean the simple answer is
just don't miss those you know I'm you
know I know I know that in the playoffs
it you know they really they want to let
him play and they and the referees don't
want to throw a flag that decides a game
that way but man that one just seemed
like it was awfully hard to miss you
know now a lot of times you know and
this calls an exception but a lot of
times you know you look at some of the
missed calls and you see it in super
slow-mo and you're like oh well
obviously I missed the call but when in
live-action it's not the same but this
one seemed to me in live-action to be
very you know it's fairly blatant and
obvious so it's just too bad you know
you really hate to see and with such
great football games on Sunday too to
see you know the game you know kind of
decided by the missed calls really it's
just sort of sad he's drew bledsoe the
former Patriots Bills Cowboys
quarterback also has double back winery
outside of Walla Walla Washington and a
great cab by the way how's the yeah
appreciate it man we're having we're
having a lot of fun but you know got to
go home my little my little home town
and we're making wine that we think is
you know it's a little it'll hold its
own with pretty much anyone in the world
man we're pretty proud of it would you
change overtime in the NFL what I change
overtime in the NFL you know I like the
college system to be honest with you I
think it's I think it's for it's
exciting you know and it's it seems to
be fairly equitable you know overtime in
the NFL I'm glad that they changed it
where you can't just you know move the
ball you know 30 yards and kick a field
goal and the game's over but you know I
don't think I don't know if they would
ever go to the college system but it's
you're exciting you watch College
overtime you know it's fun both teams
are always going to get a chance to
score and you know the one thing that
that has changed though with the new
system I you know I'd when I retired at
one record that I thought maybe would
stand up for a long long time at the
most overtime touchdown passes and you
have four or three or four overtime
touchdown passes and it used to be you
know that that would you know never get
broken because teams would just drive
down and kick a field goal he never even
trying to throw a touchdown but now
they're gonna be trying to trying to
score a touchdown so that record might
go down but when you watch Brady in that
Drive in overtime from from a
quarterbacks perspective you know
perspective who played at a high level
and like are you marveling at what
you're seeing with Brady you know when
he's with what he does that is that is
that is unique he's just he's just so
remarkably consistent you know you look
at that there that you know they were
not you know about and then that player
in that already excuse me on that driver
in that game you know there were you
know it wasn't it wasn't you know the
Patrick mahomes or Aaron Rodgers you
know Wow
you know plays it's just remarkable
consistency and the team does a great
job for him and he'd and he consistently
play it and play out does his part if
you could you know baseball big deal
with Mariano Rivera 100% above all
devotion if there was one football
player who should be the first to get
all of the votes to go into the Hall of
Fame never happened well we they're not
made public you know with the data
that kind of voting they just sort of
have a roundtable where everybody makes
their pitch for a guy and then they
argued you know pro and con well I mean
there are certain there are certain guys
you know going going back historically
that certainly should have been in that
you know on the defensive side of the
ball you look at like Lawrence Taylor
Reggie White Bruce Smith some of these
guys that really changed football on the
offensive side you know I mean shoot
Jerry Rice Joe Montana with what they
did I doze weren't unanimous and or a
guy like Barry Sanders or you know Jim
Brown you'd only get one no drew only
get one yeah I don't know Adam Vinatieri
great a greatest of all time there you
go if you could have Brady's career or
Montana's career I don't know you know
why would you why would you pick between
those guys that's that's the question
that's its tongue you got a pick have
you taken oh I don't know either one
I'm not picking that one oh come on I
mean I guess I guess you know just for
nostalgia sake you know I might go back
and be a part of those teams because
those were the teams that were there
when they were playing when I was you
know pay attention as a young kid and so
those guys were like you know they were
on a different planet they were
superheroes to me back then so I
probably picked out one but are you
saying that you wouldn't you if you pick
Montana then you're picking Montana to
be better than Brady is that what you're
worried about though you don't even know
no I'm saying I'm saying no I'm just
saying don't even don't even try that
you know you know I don't do that I
don't I don't I know but I'm saying is
that what was that your hesitation that
you know not a bit all right I don't
want to get you in trouble try to pay me
into a corner and make me do something
you know I don't because if you're
taking Montana I mean I understand that
Bledsoe picks Montana rips Brady
trying to put word yeah a bit grated up
but I've been a great politician for all
these years I've never let us media
types here hey good to talk to you and
good luck with the winery and good to
chat with you again yeah I think so
thanks buddy next time I'm next time I'm
out there I get stopped by yes again and
see if there's see if I can actually put
a hole in something with a football for
it yeah we were disappointed thought you
put a hole really I thought maybe I'd
put something but I know you reinforced
it just you left your mark on this show
thanks bud drew bledsoe for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]